the next act going into the finals is
[Applause]
just one night after the Massoud II
brothers delivered this sexy performance
with a little help from Judge julianne
hough the acrobatic trio was eliminated
on Wednesdays America's Got Talent's
Julianne with the dancing background we
thought we're gonna bring her definitely
on stage maybe next time we can play
Batman she's got those have we are
family we're brothers so everything when
we do achieve something so big and it
goes like how we planned it so that's
just the emotions come all the AGG do
you become part of the act too there's
something about feeling like you can be
an artist and a performer at the same
time and still help other people achieve
their dreams so I mean really fun Tyler
Butler Figueroa isn't the only golden
buzzer that made it through cody lee is
also moving on how do you feel I feel so
amazing how about when that entire
audience was chanting your name yeah oh
my god I chanted my I would be doing the
same thing on Tuesdays show magician
Eric Chen received some tough love from
judge Simon Cowell I really hate being
negative tonight I hadn't got a bloody
clue what was going on there sorry
unfortunately it seems like his act
didn't resonate with the audience either
[Applause]
I only had three days to create this
routine so it was very I was very
unfamiliar with this but I think I did
the best I could and I really hope
America likes it I just want to express
my dream through the world his people
here the bottom three came down to dance
crew like balance kids the end love you
youth choir and soul singer Robert
Finley based on tonight's live vote the
act you put into the finals is better
performance so far yeah well it worked
it was up to the judges to decide which
of the remaining two acts they wanted to
save that place is going to
[Applause]
Wow what did this I was like yeah
something else I couldn't be prouder of
them I push them as hard as I ever have
the combination of the music and the
choreography tonight was incredibly
difficult and technical and and they
pulled it off it's I was I'm so much
[Music]